right we're also in a very strange place
where a lot of high-profile women
will not say what they think a woman is
yeah because they are potentially Brown
Jackson the new member of the Supreme
Court in her nomination hearings was
asked a question this is what she said
as you say a Hot Topic today it could
certainly be litigated
um so I'm not in a position to to say
more about
whether or not
um it's actually one of the unenumerated
it was a riveting moment because you're
like you're going to be on the Supreme
Court of United States of America
you're a woman you're the first black
woman on the court and that in itself I
know you've raised eyebrows about why
did Joe Biden go out there and say we
need to have a black woman why not to
say we want the best person available
and then if she's the best person get
her on the court which I completely
agree with but for her not to be able to
commit to explaining what she thinks a
woman is and then I had a moment on this
show where Macy Gray the singer did
stick her neck out and she said this
I will say this and everybody's going to
hate me but as a woman just because you
go change your plots doesn't make you a
woman right sorry
you feel that
I know that for a fact like if you want
me to call you her I will because that's
what you want but that doesn't make you
a woman just because I call you or her
and it's because you got a surgery
with chilling predictability Macy Gray
stuck to her guns for a couple of days
and then the onslaught was so
overwhelming against us she had to go on
National Television in America issue a
groveling apology for everyone that
she'd hurt with this statement of what
many would think is just a statement of
biological fact
how have we got to this place where
women are terrified of saying what a
woman is and women who do say what they
think it is I.E they're a clear
biological distinctions between a man
and a woman they get destroyed well
we've accepted this Preposterous
hypothesis that your identity is only
subjectively defined and as I've tried
to point out on some of my in some of my
lectures
the only people who think their identity
is subjectively defined are
two-year-olds and I mean that
technically because two-year-olds are
egocentric which means they can't bring
their identity in alignment with a
social Norm which also means that
two-year-olds can't play with other
children they can play beside them but
they can't play with them that doesn't
happen until year three what happens
when you're three if you're reasonably
well socialized or start to move towards
that is that you learn how to negotiate
a social identity and then identity
becomes obviously it has a root some
roots in your subjectivity and in your
biology for that matter but a
sophisticated identity is not only
socially negotiated as the
constructivists know perfectly well but
it's also it's got a dynamism about it
because it has to be constantly
renegotiated like as we're having a
conversation here to some degree we're
renegotiating our mutual identities
because we learn something from each
other right so we transform right we're
also trying to figure out to some degree
who each of of us is in this situation
and then we're also trying to learn can
we play together towards some productive
end and you might ask well what do you
mean play and say well we're trying to
have an interesting conversation that's
a form of play and if you won't
negotiate and I won't negotiate how in
the world are we going to have a
conversation well this is the whole
problem with the transgender debate
particularly in things like sport is
there's simply no willingness on the
part of the transgender part of this
debate to have any conversation about
potential unfortunately creative by
what's happening and I say you've got to
have the conversation yeah but we we
talked about that earlier the people who
really push this or the ideas that
govern this was a better way of thinking
about it there is no this is a very
difficult thing to understand you think
there's such a thing as reasonable
conversation
that's not on the table for the radicals
no it's not see reason the I the your
notion of reasonable conversation is
nothing but your insistence that your
ethos is dominates and their response is
always well then you're transphobic yeah
well uh or you're racist or your body or
your biological essentialist or
something whatever it is